carrusel de las artes maria carolina
piña
[Música]
hola
bienvenidos una vez más a este espacio
donde la cultura se hace actualidad que
les presentamos desde nuestros estudios
aquí en parís a continuación los temas
que les proponemos el día de hoy
una visita al museo de la liberación de
parís donde se cuentan los pormenores de
lo que fue ese capítulo de la historia
fundamental para la victoria de los
aliados en la segunda guerra mundial
conversamos con los autores de el humano
una historieta argentina futurista
disponible ahora en francés la lectura
como terapia para el alma una nueva
forma de curar las heridas a través de
los libros y ya que la música es también
alimento para el alma escucharemos el
mensaje de paz luz y solidaridad del
marfileño alpha blondy
[Música]
carrusel de las artes los lleva hoy a
conocer un museo en parís dedicado a un
episodio histórico muy importante en
francia la liberación de la capital
francesa del dominio nazi que se celebra
cada 25 de agosto
[Música]
un nuevo museo en la capital francesa
está dedicado a la historia de la
liberación de parís
eso fue el 25 de agosto de 1944 tras
cuatro años de ocupación nazi
el museo fue construido en un lugar
estratégico para la lucha contra las
tropas alemanas como explicó a efe la
directora del museo de la liberación de
parís
sylvie set man
debajo de este edificio a 20 metros de
profundidad se encontraba lo que
llamamos un refugio subterráneo de
defensa pasiva un lugar diseñado para
resistir en caso de bombardeo este
refugio sirvió de cuartel de comando al
estado mayor de las fuerzas francesas
durante la semana de la insurrección de
parís
aquí se coordinaron las acciones que
llevaron a la liberación de la capital y
de las ampa
[Música]
los alemanes tomaron el control de parís
durante cuatro largos años el general de
gaulle el jefe de la francia libre
convenció a los aliados para que parís
fuera liberada para el tomar el control
de parís era todo un símbolo y una
jugada política de sus hijos
tarde
podéis de tarin barker y de
de ésta
el museo expone más de 300 documentos y
está dedicado a dos figuras emblemáticas
jean moulin uno de los líderes de la
resistencia que en murió torturado antes
de la liberación y el general nuclear
quien logró la liberación de parís al
frente de la segunda división blindada
una unidad militar francesa compuesta
también por extranjeros bando
nacionalista donde venden ese ejército
había 22 nacionalidades diferentes
hugo venezolanos argentinos y una unidad
española la 9 ellos fueron los primeros
en entrar y combatir junto a la
resistencia y los soldados franceses
para liberar a la ciudad el museo está
diseñado para que el público pueda
comprender este episodio tan importante
de la historia de francia
compongo este nuevo
en francia se celebra este año el año de
la historieta y hoy vamos a conocer a un
dúo de argentinos que escribió una
novela gráfica de ciencia ficción se
llama el humano y los conocimos en el
festival de angulema los detalles con
abel lópez
[Música]
o
un futuro en la tierra muy muy lejano
donde queda un solo hombre robert él es
el humano de esta nueva novela gráfica
futurista que nos lleva a plantearnos
una situación límite para la humanidad
qué pasaría si estuviéramos solos cuáles
serían nuestros límites el humano dibuja
el camino a la locura en el que la única
herramienta salvadora podría ser un
robot psicólogo de aspecto femenino
[Música]
a mí me interesaba como investigar en el
hecho de que siendo el último hombre en
la tierra todos los condicionamientos
morales son relativos porque no tenía
que comportarse bien ante nadie más no
había otro humano con el cual mantener
una regla de convivencia por ejemplo
solo estaban sus robots que eran
esclavos básicamente de sí mismos así
que se decide hacer cualquier tipo de
calamidad total no hay nadie para
juzgarlo allí salvo esta alfa que es la
robot que tiene que hacer la terapeuta
de este hombre que está completamente
desatado con todos sus vicios y lo peor
de toda nuestra raza en una sola persona
he decidido hacer cualquier cosa total
yo no hay nadie que lo pueda juzgar es
un poco una pregunta que quedaría uno en
esa situación si no tenés a quien
responder que permita un juicio sobre
vos qué es lo que uno podría llegar a
hacer
[Música]
lucas varela se encargó de dibujar esta
novela gráfica apocalíptica con una
paleta limitada de rojos grises y
marrones el personaje principal de
robert es un ejemplo de la masculina
tóxica no hay cómo se destruye a sí
mismo
al final de la historia y es todo un
descenso del personaje a la locura la
autodestrucción el humano mezcla ciencia
ficción relato apocalíptico y una buena
dosis de análisis psiquiátrico frente a
la soledad y el aislamiento o a mi madre
psiquiatra llegado habrá tenido que ver
y después creo que sí que es de una
cultura psicoanalítica muy grande que
nos atraviesa más allá de que queramos o
no analizar todo de buscarles de
prestaciones a los hechos a los símbolos
a los signos sigue por ese lado por ser
argentinos que bueno frase tampoco es
que tengan pocos psicólogos así que
tienen la can y otros escuela
psicoanalítica se entera de 800 cierta
atracción por las historias de gente
desesperada de la locura desatada y eso
me atrae mucho para meterme en una
historia
ah
si pudiéramos superar la timidez la
ansiedad o el estrés a través de los
libros es lo que buscan los adeptos de
la biblioterapia una nueva disciplina
que está ganando terreno en francia- nos
lo cuenta melissa barra para conectarse
con su propia feminidad esta memoria de
mujer de anger no está el libro de mi
madre de al vasco en para aquellos que
han perdido la suya magia asocia una
obra literaria muy precisa a cada
problema de la vida y cuando se enfermó
fue también un libro que la ayudó a
calmar su sufrimiento
el libro que más me conmovió fue el
dolor demagógicas su dolor era tan
intenso que sentí que mi propia pena era
no tanto relativa pero más tenue y eso
me permitió superarla me parece que es
muy interesante porque es catártico
sanar con los libros tiene un nombre se
llama biblioterapia una corriente que
proviene de eeuu y cuyos adeptos
aumentan
francia en su gabinete parisino o gel
yermo recibe a pacientes en busca de
soluciones literarias hoy por ejemplo
una mujer ha venido tras la muerte de su
padre y esto es lo que le recomienda el
primero sería resucitar de cristian
bombón habla de pérdidas de duelos de
muerte pero también de vida de
renacimiento de felicidad y de belleza
el libro tiene momentos emocionales
fuertes pero es radios o con ayuda de un
cuestionario o gel yermo analiza los
gustos y las necesidades de los
pacientes perfecta y salva
igualmente lo que les puede hacer vibrar
lo que despierte algo en ellos para
ayudarlos a avanzar que les dé ganas de
leer algo que no acostumbran a leer
novelas poemas lecturas en voz alta o
baja
los defensores de la biblioterapia
diseñan un tratamiento y dosis para cada
paciente el único efecto secundario del
libro medicamento es no querer volver a
cerrarlo nunca
[Música]
vamos ahora al universo colorido del
reagge de la mano de un cantante que
viene de costa de marfil alpha blondy es
toda una autoridad en ese terreno y lo
conocimos en la última edición del
festival de soho que vamos allá con
natalio olivares
[Música]
con más energía que nunca hay una
prestancia única la estrella marfileña
alpha blondy de 66 años recorre el mundo
para presentar su disco human righs y el
mismo mensaje de siempre paz y libertad
para todos dijo que él haga ximena mi
álbum habla de la raza humana que no es
una raza desdichada porque tenemos
tendencia a creer lo que dicen los
periódicos y los medios de comunicación
men check in paris está pasión johnson
set media sense millón hábito a ver el
lado negativo de nuestra raza y esto no
es correcto porque hay que saber que la
tierra y siete mil millones de seres
humanos nos fijamos sobre las desgracias
que hacen mil millones de personas
cuando quedan en total seis mil millones
de personas que son buenas que son
positivas me gustaría que la humanidad
se concentrará en ese lado positivo y no
en el lado de la oscuridad del allí paso
el ocote tiene vuelve
ya no están
el que muchos consideran como el papá
del rey y francófono y africano nos
recibió en el festival les digo que en
breve
asegura que su creencia en dios es un
motor así como su disco alpha blondy
promociona la idea de solidaridad un
concepto y un estilo de vida que los
jóvenes deben defender optimista con los
jóvenes soy optimista aunque al
escucharlo a veces es como si hubieran
inventado el agua tibia a veces dicen
que mamá no entienden nada al amor que
papá no sabe nada pero es así es la vida
yo también lo pensé pero es una etapa
porque algún día terminarán por pensar
como mamá o como papá hay que decirles
que ellos también son el fruto de dios y
dios es amor también esto es positivo
tengo fe en ellos y tengo fe en el
futuro ella fue a la venera alpha blondy
no piensa jubilar seguirá recordando a
la juventud que él fue testigo del
racismo las dictaduras y del terrorismo
cosas que hay que combatir sin descanso
en el escenario al tablón gana la pelea
y reúne a la gente cual sea su color su
origen o su herencia
mensaje
caníbales
cuentan que viviendo
lo que me tiene a mí
[Música]
con la sonrisa y la energía de alpha
blondy vamos a despedir este carrusel de
las artes muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros cuídense mucho y
hasta la próxima
agua
[Música]
m
él
no es algo
[Música]
de maquinista
a mí
[Aplausos]
a menos que me mires
[Música]